[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute habe ich mal ein
richtig schokoladige bisher für euch wir
haben hier nämlich einen riesen und
darin befindet sich ein fast
schokokuchen mit einer leckeren
kinderriegel trieben einen teller suppe
und getoppt wird das ganze noch mit
kinderriegel und kinder happy hippos und
ich möchte auch gerne lange drum herum
reden wir starten jetzt mit der
zubereitung des die form für das
überraschungsei habe ich aus dem
internet bestellt und ich werde euch den
link auf jeden fall in die infobox
setzen denn es war gar nicht so einfach
so eine form in der größe zu finden und
die hat sogar in abgeflachten boden das
heißt die form kann auch nachher schönen
standhaft stehen bleiben und da gebe ich
jetzt meine geschmolzene förmig chöre
hinein
die schokolade geht jetzt in der form
verteilt und dafür dreht ihr die form am
besten immer wieder gibt ja auch ruhig
mehr kuvertüre mit hinein das sieht am
ende sowieso alles ausgegossen
sobald dann die oberfläche des als
komplett mit der ouvertüre bedeckt wurde
geben wir den rest zurück in die schüsse
sternstraße ich den rest noch mit meiner
winkel palette ab und gebe das als und
kühlen und aushärten in den kühlschrank
nun ist die schokolade komplett
ausgehärtet und ich gebe noch eine
zweite schicht der vollmilch kuvertüre
drauf damit ich mehr stabilität habe
auch hier wird wieder reichlich probe
türe in die form gegeben anschließend
das ganze gut an die ränder verteilen
und den überschuss zurückgeben
jetzt muss die zweite schicht auch
auskühlen am besten im kühlschrank dann
geht das ganze superschnell und in der
zwischenzeit habe ich mir auch schon
weiße kuvertüre geschmolzen und gäbe
dass auf die dunkle schicht hier
verfahren wie genauso wie bei der
vollmilch kuvertüre und wenn wir dann
die ränder auch mit der weißen drüber
türe bedeckt haben geben wir den
überschuss zurück in unsere schüssel und
lassen das ganze aus herten bei dem aus
gießen der form sollte die kuvertüre
nicht zu heiß sein am besten temperiert
ihr seid dann seid ihr auf der sicheren
seite
ich habe dazu was in die infobox
beschrieben schotte am besten mal rein
den leckeren schokokuchen benötigen wir
zwei eier die hier hatten die größe es
deswegen habe ich da noch ein paar
schlucke milch dazu gegeben außerdem 100
gramm zucker 30 gramm bacau 5 gramm
backpulver 50 gramm mehl und 20 gramm
stärke und hier habe ich noch 80 gramm
butter die sollte am besten
zimmertemperatur haben zuallererst wird
die butter gemeinsam mit dem zucker mit
eurem handrührgerät ziemlich geschlagen
es dauert zwei bis drei minuten unter
macht gibt ihr die eier mit hinzu
[Musik]
die eier müssen auch nur ganz kurz mit
untergerührt werden so lange bis sich
die masse miteinander verbunden hat die
trockenen zutaten hatte ich ja bereits
alle in eine schüssel und die sich jetzt
mit hinzu damit auch keine klümpchen
entstehen
[Musik]
während ich die trockenen zutaten in den
teig an arbeite erkenne ich schon ob ich
noch etwas flüssigkeit benötige er
gesagt hatte ich die eier hier in der
größe ist und deshalb gebe ich noch ein
paar schritte mädchen zu
[Musik]
nachdem ich die trockenen zutaten
abwechselnd mit der milch in den teig
gegeben habe ist auch schon fertig und
kann gebacken werden
[Musik]
die konsequenz das teilte sohn etwa wie
einen muffin teig sein und die form die
ihr jetzt zum backen benutzt sie ist
eigentlich total egal ich zeige mich
auch später warum davon erkennt man
nämlich später gar nichts mehr
ich habe hier jetzt meine typische
brownie form genommen hat sie mit
backpapier eingekleidet und gebe den
teig mit hinein
[Musik]
nachdem ich alles grob verstrichen habe
wirklich in den vorgeheizten backofen
bei 180 grad ca 14 minuten die nutella
creme habe ich hier 130 gramm erwärmte
nutella und 50 milliliter heiße sahne
und das vermisse ich jetzt miteinander
die beiden zutaten sollten auch warm bzw
heiß sein damit es sich gut miteinander
vermischen kann und die konsistenz
sollte fließend sein
die fertige nutella soße kann jetzt
erstmal an die seite gelegt werden und
mein fertiger schokokuchen wird in
kleine stücke geschnitten
dadurch dass der kuchen jetzt ziemlich
frisch ist natürlich etwas weich das
macht aber gar nichts im gegenteil ich
finde das schmeckt sogar viel besser
die form des schokokuchen sieht man
hinterher sowieso nicht mehr bestehen
könnte sie auch ruhig in einer runden
springform backen beziehungsweise das
was wir gerade da habt überraschungsei
wird jetzt aus der form geholt und das
geht auch ziemlich schnell und einfach
das dauert keine zwei sekunden einfach
von unten heraus drücken
[Musik]
in das überraschungsei fülle ich jetzt
als allererstes mein schokokuchen
[Musik]
darauf gebe ich dann die nutella soße so
dass beinahe alles bedeckt ist
[Musik]
darauf gebe ich dann nochmal
schokokuchen und nutella soße
[Musik]
jetzt wird das ganze noch mit meiner
kinder riegel creme getoppt dazu gibt es
bereits ein extra video das verlinkt ich
euch auch in der infobox gefühlt habe
ich das in meine 2d thüle von wilden und
spritze damit großen aus
[Musik]
nachdem die creme dann komplett darauf
verteilt wurde
geben wir darauf unsere
lieblingsschokolade in meinem fall habe
ich kinder segel und kinder hätte hier
vorgenommen
[Musik]
natürlich wäre das bisher jetzt fertig
aber ich würde ja nicht schokoladig für
das ja überhaupt sein wenn wir das ganze
nicht noch mit der note heller soße
toppen und jetzt gibt noch alles was er
von der soße übrig habt auch das dessert
und dann ist wirklich fertig
[Musik]
und jetzt stellt sich eigentlich nur
noch eine einzige frage wie ist man das
ganze in nehmt euch am besten einen
löffel so wie ich euch das video zeige
und löffelt ihr dass dies sehr einfach
aus
am besten zeigt ihr das natürlich mit
der familie oder mit euren freunden denn
es ist doch ganz schön kalorienhaltig
wenn ihr einen schlechten tag hatte dann
dürfte das auch gerne alleine essen da
ich glaube ich auch keine bedrohung und
wenn ihr mehr davon sehen möchtet dann
abonniert doch gerne den kanal last
einen daumen hoch da und ich dachte ich
zum nächsten mal auf welches kitchen